il faut avoir peur parce que les
unionistes fallait il ya vraiment c'est
une partie de l'extrême droite
britannique il faut pas ce sont des anti
européens mais pas simplement ce sont
aussi des xénophobes se sont globalement
c'est une partie très très dur
donc ils ont des groupes paramilitaires
et en face il ya évidemment toute une
tradition une histoire de résistance à
l'occupation britannique
donc oui il faut avoir peur il faut
avoir peur qu'au sein même de l'union
européenne
on voit des conflits ce sera révisée et
et en plus il ya des questions sociales
très fortes et c'est donc oui il faut
avoir peur il faut qu'on reste sur une
logique de démocratie de paix et de
négocier